now it's time for the final thought I
have to put my smart glasses on for the
final thought because I can't read the
prompter a little bit of knowledge is a
dangerous thing so if you want to defend
Western culture which is a laudable and
urgent endeavor you might first ask
yourself what is Western culture what
created Western culture
what does Western culture comprise white
nationalists like Richard Spencer seem
to answer with shallow pop philosophy
and slick memes now it's a great thing
to unite the right but not with the
wrong all right reads Nietzsche
conservatives understand easy and there
are more things in heaven and earth than
are dreamt of in our philosophy this
eternal fact should suffice to keep
people out of Hell unless like the
clowns who paraded through
Charlottesville this weekend they're
already there and determined to drag us
down into the filth with them on that
I'm Michael Noel's this is the Michael
Nolt oh come back tomorrow and we'll do
it again
[Music]